so tom brady do to become a free agent
if you haven't heard and if you haven't
heard where in the hell have you been
where have you the biggest name free
agent in years if not ever
due to hit the market unless he re-signs
with the patriots and the chargers have
been mentioned as a possible team and
look if the chargers want to try to
compete in la he's the kind of guy they
should be targeting austin eckler who
recently signed a four-year contract to
stay with the chargers presumably as
their top running back was on nfl
network and he made the pitch
for tom brady tyrod taylor may not be
happy about that said austin eckley we
just lost a lot of leadership in philip
rivers so it's like all right there's a
void there also russell oakland one of
our tackles got traded he was one of our
team leaders as well so there's a void
in leadership it's an opportunity for
people to step up but if you bring a guy
like tom brady in the room he's been
there done that he's already got the
leadership qualities and he's already
proven that he's a winner so hey we can
build something around that too well
tyrod taylor's also a leader not
necessarily a winner yet but uh i i
think it makes a ton of sense
for the chargers to be interested in tom
brady from a team standpoint
from a business standpoint i don't know
that it makes sense for brady peter
because then he's got to deal with
patrick mahomes and the chiefs twice a
year and compete with them in the
division but if i'm the chargers i'm at
the front of the line to try to get this
guy
well i would agree with you totally on
that mike and you know to me i think the
biggest issue becomes
what is your team and i think like tom
telesco who's the general manager of
this team
comes from the bill polian school of
draft and develop and i don't mean this
to be a cliche he's obviously stepped
out of character sometimes and gone and
signed free agents i get that but in
this particular case it's a totally
different year you're moving into a new
stadium
uh and you're moving into a stadium at a
time
when uh everybody is wondering who's
gonna show up they didn't show up in a
28 000 seat stadium are they going to
show up at a 70 000 seat stadium and so
that is the big issue the chargers face
and look
you're only going to continue to get
fans if you win i get it the temptation
to sign tom brady and to sell out x
number of games in your first year has
to be great for dean spanos and it's got
to be tempting
uh for even a draft and develop guy like
tom telesco yeah i get it from the
charger standpoint yeah i mean you're
right it makes a lot of sense we know
that i mean uh now i would say like okay
they just got rid of an old quarterback
do they really want to go down that road
again you know yo it's tom brady it's
probably worth it you are second fiddle
there in in in that city you know i
understand that but i think ultimately i
just don't see brady wanting to be a
part of that in any capacity you know
for a few reasons mike you mentioned the
first one i don't think he's going to
want to deal with patrick mahomes and
what oh man i mean oh maybe if i get to
the playoffs we can go to the wild card
game all right i don't think he wants to
be a part of a team that's going to be
second fiddle in a city i don't see that
being a thing either there's a horrible
offensive line there with the chargers i
don't think a guy that 43 wants to deal
with that and then i also don't think
the chargers and their coaching staff
are enough of a proven commodity to make
him want to go there and go oh
i trust that group can build something
special so i get it from all those other
angles and if i'm austin eckler i'd say
those things too i mean come on brady's
awesome i've only had one issue with
brady in my whole life he's amazing as a
person i loved being around him when i
was he's smart he's funny he's
hard-working he's humble all of those
things but i just can't imagine him uh
wanting to go to to the chargers and
play there
yeah and look tom telesco has said he's
not trying to sell tickets he's trying
to win games and he's being careful with
making big splashes but ultimately
you're in los angeles and if it's not
tom brady they need to be swinging a
trade for cam newton they need to do
something they need that billboard guys
you used that term earlier peter they
need someone who can help them compete
with the rams so that when the tickets
are gonna sell
the question is when you walk out of the
tunnel is it a road game because the
stadium has been overrun by the fans of
the team that you're hosting
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports